speaking of strange headlines
we got a strange headline actually from
the daily wire it's not just the daily
wire though strange headline that's
coming from pretty much every news
outlet in the country and the headline
is this
wnba star brittany griner sentenced to
nine years in russian prison and i think
this is the first time that the daily
wire has ever published fake news
because they accuse us of publishing
fake news all the time i don't think we
have until
yesterday when this article came out
because there is no such thing as a wnba
star
right can't we all agree on that
regardless of what you think about the
brittany griner situation what's going
on in russia right now i think left and
right
should all we should all be able to
agree there is no such category as wnba
star
the only reason
that anyone has ever heard this lady's
name is because she's been arrested for
smuggling drugs into russia
and the only reason that anyone is even
talking about the wnba is because of
this international incident that was
prompted by this anti-american lady
athlete's
drug problem and her her trip to russia
to try to make money in an off-season
basketball league so brittany griner for
those who have not followed the story
and that includes me i didn't follow the
story until yesterday when this was
being blasted all over the headlines
brittany greiner is a lady basketball
player she plays in the wnba and she the
wnba players because they don't make
very much money because nobody watches
the wnba they play in these leagues
overseas where they can make a little
bit more money and so she was playing in
some russian basketball games and she
flies over and she brings a bunch of
hashish oil
she brings a bunch of the distilled
essence of the devil's lettuce and this
is a big no-no in russia russia has much
much stricter drug laws than america
does i think most countries have
stricter drug laws than america does and
so she gets stopped and she's arrested
and she goes to trial and she was just
sentenced yesterday to nine years in a
russian prison
how are we supposed to feel about this
well i'll tell you
i'll tell you one of the things that
informed how i feel about this i googled
brittany griner i had obviously never
heard of her before and one of the first
things to pop up is this article from a
couple years ago in the washington post
brittany griner
brianna turner call for the wnba to stop
playing the national anthem
this season because they don't they
don't like the national anthem the
national anthem is the star-spangled
banner the star-spangled banner is the
symbol of our entire country
so i don't
i don't know any way to interpret
britney griner's actions a couple years
ago
i think through the present
other than she doesn't like america she
hates america
and she's playing in some foreign league
and then she breaks their laws and then
she comes running back begging america
to help her and i got to tell you
i'm not the well is dry here i'm trying
to muster tears for brittany griner in
her present predicament they're not
coming they're not coming i just don't i
guess
i guess generally i lean on the side of
it would be good to bring her home
i'm
51 49 on that side because
certainly russia is going to use her for
political leverage to try to either have
a prisoner swap with america or to try
to put put some political pressure for
america to ease up on some of the
sanctions or whatever so she is going to
be used as a political pawn but i'm
still 51 49 here because i have to ask
myself this other question
does russia have a right
to make its own drug laws
i think so i think russia has a right to
make its own drug laws
are russia's drug laws being selectively
applied to this lady basketball player
no certainly not there's another story
no one's talking about this we're all
talking now about the lady basketball
player well just last month you you see
a story from this is right here in the
bbc russia sentences u.s teacher to 14
years for cannabis smuggling so it's the
same sort of issue here but because he's
not
in a woke kind of sports league
no one's talking about him really in the
press you get one article here in the
bbc but this guy
was
uh he he was discovered with his drugs
at moscow's airport in 2021
and he uh he was uh i guess he was a
former us diplomat he's now teaching
in a school
and he brought in some pot same issue
that brianna or whatever her name is
brittany griner was caught with here in
russia
why are we talking about him maybe he'll
be part of some deal okay maybe
the other aspect of this so does russia
have the right to make its own drug laws
i think so yeah we have the right to
make our own drug laws other countries
have the rights to make their own drug
blows i think russia has the same rights
then the next question is
are russia's drug laws totally insane in
draconian i don't think so russia's drug
laws are just what the american drug
laws were like 25 or 30 years ago
when america's drug laws made a lot more
sense
do we think it's good that we have
liberalized all the drug laws and
encouraged people to take more drugs i
don't think that's good i think that's
really bad we've got the worst drug drug
overdose problem in american history
right now the problem is so acute that
the american life expectancy has
actually declined for the first time
ever but multiple years in a row and
it's declined because of deaths of
despair largely
we're talking about suicide and we're
talking about drug overdoses
major major issues especially with young
people overdosing on drugs i bet i know
people who in the last two three years
have overdosed on drugs people i thought
would never have a drug problem
i i'm
certain that the vast majority of you
know someone who's overdosed on drugs in
recent years opioids fentanyl whatever
so yeah i say i actually think russia's
drug laws make a hell of a lot more
sense than america's drug laws do
sometimes you'll hear people say well in
america we throw people in prison for
carrying a dime bag of pot that's not
true we actually don't do that
we we barely throw drug dealers in
prison drug peddlers in prison and when
you allow drug dealers and drug peddlers
to operate you you poison the country
and you you enrich criminal cartels i
think it makes a whole lot more sense
what we see in russia
and so then you got to ask yourself why
am i shedding a tear for brittany griner
the only reason that she's even
appearing in the news is because she is
super woke and she hates america so
sorry lady cry me a river i'm just not
i'm just not there i think the lesson
that we should take from this here's a
psa for everyone out there traveling
overseas don't smuggle drugs into
foreign countries lesson number two
don't smuggle drugs into hostile foreign
countries lesson number three don't
smuggle drugs into hostile foreign
countries that have had nuclear weapons
pointed at the heads of you and your
countrymen for the last 70 years okay
that's that's my psa to everybody the
other lesson that we should maybe learn
here is
maybe we could learn a thing or two from
the way that other countries are dealing
with the drug problem before our entire
country overdoses on dope because we're
because we're a nation of dopes these
days not the regular american people but
the political leadership no question
about it right now text knowles to
989898 the consumer price index has
reached yet another 40-year high the
latest gdp numbers confirmed that the
united states is in a recession despite
the best efforts of the current
administration to redefine what
recession means we are right this second
in a recession take action to protect
your savings from a highly turbulent
economy right now by diversifying at
least some of your investment portfolio
into gold and silver from birch gold
group text knolls k w l e s to 989898
and birch gold will send you a free
information kit on how to transition an
ira or eligible 401k into an ira in
precious metals birch gold will even
help you hold gold in a tax sheltered
account for decades investors have
relied on gold and silver as a hedge
against inflation now you can too here
we are here's the inflation with an a
plus rating for the better business
bureau countless five-star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers secure
your future with gold from birch gold
right now text knowles k-w-l-e-s to 9 8
9 8 9 8 get real help from birch gold
today that is knowles text it to 989898
claim your free no obligation
information kit on how to protect your
hard-earned savings with gold
so glad you liked that clip now hold up
wait don't go look i know i got a
million subscribers here on youtube
that's great i'm thrilled i'm very
grateful to all of you who took us to
that level now i want to reach
1 trillion
i know it's a little bit of a lofty goal
i want to do it i think we can you've
got to subscribe ring the bell get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]